l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 468 de monsieur alain
gournac à madame la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre j'ai été
prévenue pas d'amour touraine pouvait
pas être là mais je suis heureux que ce
soit vous qui me répondiez ce matin
ma question souhaite attirer l'attention
de madame la ministre sur le cancer des
enfants précisément sur le cancer des
enfants
celui ci constitue la première cause de
mortalité des enfants par maladie chaque
année en effet dans notre pays 2500
enfants sont atteints d'un cancer et 500
en meurent un enfant sur 440 sera
atteint d'un cancer avant l'âge de 15
ans
ces chiffres sont en progression
d'environ 2 % chaque année cela fait 30
ans 30 ans que l'espérance de vie de
certains cancers pédiatriques comme les
tumeurs cérébrales n'a pas progressé le
cancer des enfants est un problème de
santé publique or seulement 2% des fonds
alloués à la recherche sur le cancer
sont alloués à celui des enfants et des
tur gens de guérir en plus grand nombre
et mieux les enfants des adolescents
atteints de cancer et de réduire ça
c'est important les séquelles à long
terme des traitements toxiques et
agressifs qu'ils subissent ça c'est la
suite de la vie aussi convient-il de
développer une recherche biologique
spécifique sur les cancers pédiatriques
afin d'obtenir de nouveaux médicaments
appropriés aux enfants et cc ainsi
d'être contraints d'utiliser des
médicaments élaboré pour soigner les
cancers de l'adulte on donne des doses
plus faibles il est nécessaire de
garantir aux enfants et aux adolescents
l'accès aux technologies innovantes de
biologie moléculaire et d'imagerie
fonctionnelle pour individualiser les
traitements et leur proposer une
médecine adaptés et personnalisés il y a
plusieurs sortes de cancer il faut donc
s'adapter à chaque sorte de cancer il
conviendrait de tripler le nombre de
nouveaux médicaments anti co c'est re
développer en france de renforcer la
recherche et l'évaluation de nouvelles
stratégies thérapeutiques
il faudra également structuré et
systématiser le suivi à long terme des
enfants guéris après et enfin mettre en
oeuvre une recherche clinique et
génétiques pour réduire les
complications chez les adultes guéri
d'un cancer dans leur enfance aussi je
vous demande quelles mesures le
gouvernement entend mettre en oeuvre
pour relever ce défi de santé publique
et notamment quelle place il entend
réserver à ces mesures dans le plan
cancer 3 qui devrait très prochainement
lancer
merci
merci monsieur gournac madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur je suis heureuse que vous ayez
pu nous rejoindre à temps pour que je
vous apporte la réponse de de marisol
touraine qui m'a chargé à sa place
puisqu'elle est retenue de vous apporter
une réponse et je le fais d'autant plus
volontiers que mon département de
l'aveyron est celui qui accueille tous
les ans l'opération on chante tous je
crois qu'ils aient cette belle opération
justement sur pour participer au
financement de l'aide pour le cancer des
enfants chaque année en france près de
2500 nouveaux cas de cancer sont
diagnostiqués chez les enfants et
adolescents en 30 ans le taux de survie
des enfants atteints du cancer c'est
quand même considérablement amélioré
passant de 25% à près de 80% c'est une
indication je crois qu'ils nous
apportent un peu de baume au coeur dans
le cadre du plan cancer 2009 2013
plusieurs appels à projet avait été
lancé par l'institut national du cancer
pour soutenir les projets intégrés et
novateur en faveur de la prise en charge
des adolescents et des jeunes adultes
atteints du cancer pour le suivi des
patients traités pour un cancer durant
l'enfance ou l'adolescence
actuellement des actions de santé
publique sont en cours avec deux
registres nationaux spécialisés des
cancers de l'enfant un sur les ihm les
hémopathies malignes et un sur les
humeurs solide les tumeurs solides une
plate forme d'observation des cancers de
l'enfant localisé au centre de lutte
contre le cancer
villejuif permet d'améliorer les
connaissances et puy-de-dôme lieu
épidémiologique en lien avec la biologie
dans le cadre de la recherche des
actions sont engagées par l'institut
national du cancer l'institut thématique
multi-organismes cancer ont été
développés dans les domaines de la
biologie des facteurs de risque décence
humaine et sociale de l'épidémiologie de
la santé publique et des facteurs
environnementaux et génétiques liées au
cancer plusieurs essais cliniques à
promotion académiques et industriels
sont actuellement ouverts aux inclusion
des enfants atteints de cancer dont
environ un quart inclut des enfants avec
un cancer cérébral ces essais cliniques
et thérapeutiques correspondent à des
programmes de recherche qui porte
notamment sur la radiothérapie les
faibles et fortes doses de radiation en
relation avec les cancers de l'enfant et
la prise en charge des cancers
pédiatriques
elles correspondent à un financement
significatif
puisque entre 2007 et 2011 leur
financement a été 2 38 millions d'euros
de nombreuses associations de parents et
vous le savez on leur disais à l'instant
se sont fortement investis dans le
soutien à la recherche dans
l'amélioration de la qualité des soins
de la prise en charge du jeune patient
et de l'accompagnement de leurs familles
pour autant les efforts et le
gouvernement en est pleinement conscient
doivent être poursuivi et intensifié
c'est pourquoi le président de la
république a annoncé le 4 décembre 2012
l'élaboration d'un nouveau plan cancer
que vous appelez de vos voeux un plan
actuellement en cours d'élaboration dans
lequel la question des cancers des
enfants il figurera comme l'une des
priorités l'une des priorités dans le
cadre de la lutte contre les inégalités
aux plus jeunes âges de la vie soyez sûr
que je ferai part de votre question tout
particulièrement à madame la ministre de
la santé
merci madame la ministre monsieur
gournac madame la minute vrai vous
remercier et moi aussi vous savez j'ai
tremblé parce que c'est certainement
depuis que je suis au cdh à la question
la plus importante que je n'ai jamais
posé et me trouver n'ayant pas de
transport avoir des embouteillages dans
paris j'en étais malade mais philippe
bas je le salue était d'accord pour
poser ma question et il l'aurait fait
très bien ma passe moi je vais vous
remercier mais ce que je vous redis
est-ce qu'il faut dire madame la
ministre que je souhaite nous souhaitons
voir dans le plan cancer qui va être
élaboré ce quelque chose de bien visible
en ce qui concerne le cancer deux des
enfants et ensuite le fait que quand on
les a sortis de ce sens ce cancer que
l'on puisse les suivre pour qu'ils aient
une vie normale parce que c'est bien
d'être sauvés et d'ailleurs vous nous
avez parlé d'une association que vous
connaissez bien je connais bien
l'endroit où a lieu cela mais je moi je
travaille avec une association qui
s'appelle imagine fort margot présidée
par madame patricia blanquette ici qui
fait un travail remarquable et organise
avec le professeur gilles vassal j'ai
pas si vous connaissez c'est un
professeur remarquable remarquable
directeur de la recherche qui de
l'institut gate gustave roussy à
villejuif une grande mobilisation
appelait la marche enfants sans cancer
et cette grande manifestation aura lieu
au domaine national de saint cloud le 29
septembre prochain donc voyez les
actions que vous menez dans votre
département les actions que nous menons
dans la région parisienne tout ça quand
nous permettre de faire mieux et non pas
madame les miches termine là dessus ne
prenait pas mal de dire bon on donne une
pilule pour un adulte on va lui donner
une demie puis de loin car de pilules ça
c'est pas du traitement nous voulons une
recherche pour le cancer spécifique pour
le cancer des enfants je vous remercie
beaucoup mais je sais que vous êtes
sensibles et vous n'allez pas m'oublier